Alo
alo alo.
Xin chào các bạn.
Không biết các bạn có nghe rõ không?
Có nghe rõ không? À ok. Có vẻ có tiếng
rồi. Xin chào các bạn.
Hôm nay rất là tình cờ bất ngờ. Mình
cũng mới quyết định livestream cách đây
chỉ vài phút trước khi mà có bạn
kiểu đôi khi là tình cờ có một bạn à.
Đây mình mở đèn ra cho sáng lên tí đã. Ơ
cắm rồi mà.
Cầm cái này cầm cái gì vậy? Cậy mình tí
mở đèn lên cho nó trông sáng sủa một tí.
Đó.
Đấy thêm hiệu ứng đó. Rất nhiều ánh đèn
đây.
Hôm nay có một bạn tình cớ vào Discord
kiểu tầm vài tháng này hay là vài tuần
gì đấy. Thấy có một bạn tình cờ vào
Discord nên mình kiểu khá bất ngờ. Kiểu
bạn này từ đâu đến vậy.
Nên là hôm nay cũng có bạn nói mình lâu
không thấy mình thì mình xin phép chia
sẻ buổi hôm nay. Ờ
để mà nói là mình cũng phải ngồi xem lại
kiểu lần cuối mình livestream là về cái
gì đấy. Cũng cũng mới chỉ tầm 2 tháng
trước thôi. Nó cũng không phải giống như
hồi trước là mất tích tậm
kiểu nửa năm thậm chí 1 năm hay gì đó.
Ờ
hôm nay tuy là bảo là gọi là ở đây gọi
là đường đến
con đường đến phỏng vấn đúng không ạ?
Phần bố phần bốn nhưng mà thực tế là
mình nghĩ là mình sẽ chia sẻ cho các bạn
trước câu chuyện của mình kiểu gọi là
gần đây mình đã thay đổi những cái gì
đúng không ạ? Cũng để mà nói là lần cuối
mình livestream so bây giờ là mình thấy
là mình đã trưởng thành hơn khá nhiều
đấy. Mình tự tin là như thế. Trưởng
thành ở đây không phải mỗi a
không phải mỗi về tuổi đương nhiên là
tuổi nó vẫn thế đúng không ạ?
à mà trưởng thành thêm về đầu tiên là về
sự nghiệp này, công việc kiểu tư duy hay
là
các mối quan hệ vân vân các thứ. Uầy
đang từ không người theo dõi không người
xem tự nhiên lên bảy người xem rồi. Có
vẻ đúng đến 8 giờ là
cũng đúng như hồi trước. Tầm cũng chỉ có
một vài bạn xem nhất định. Ơ mất mạng à?
Đừng mà mất mạng nhá.
Mấy ông thấy mạng có vấn đề thì báo tôi
nhá. Sao
mạng yếu này?
Mấy ông thách thấy mất mạng gì không ạ?
Thấy đường truyền ổn định không ạ? không
thấy không thấy ai bình luận gì cả nên
không biết nào. Và đây là bộ dạng của
tôi hàng ngày nên là mấy ông cũng thông
cảm nếu mà trông nó không a gọi như là ừ
trông thế này mới toát ra kiểu lập trình
viên đấy ạ.
20 người nhưng mà không có người bình
luận cũng như là không biết
không biết mấy ông xem. Alo alo
mấy ông có à đây có một bình luận rồi.
Ok xin cảm ơn vậy.
À cái này để tiếng để tự động tiếng Anh
khó chịu quá.
Không có cách nào đổi nhỉ.
Ơ hello anh
đâu sao không cách nào để nó mặc định để
tiếng
ngôn ngữ nhỉ
để mặc định tiếng Anh ạ. Are you
planning to change job tí anh anh chuẩn
bị nhảy việc à chính xác là à như nào
nhỉ?
Thì đấy tôi đang định chia sẻ nghĩa là
trong vòng 2 tháng qua có những cái gì
đã xảy ra. Đầu tiên là về mối quan hệ
của tôi là tôi ở bề tôi đã mới cầu hôn
vợ và cũng mới làm à
à dãm ngõ đấy thì tức là tôi sắp lấy vợ
đấy.
Tôi không vào kinh thầy với chung thầy
hay quá không dạo này thì số cân vẫn thế
đấy vẫn còn nếu mà sau hồi trước là tôi
béo hơn đấy chắc là do mặt thôi chứ bụng
thôi dồn hết xuống bụng rồi không ạ mang
tế không uống bia đấy à đấy nghĩa là
mình sắp lập gia đình rồi này ờ về công
việc thì là
10 tháng trước thôi. 10 tháng trước tôi
là tôi đã
ở trong cái diện mà kiểu gọi là rất là
nguy hiểm.
Bởi vì công ty của tôi hiện tại tôi
thường chia sẻ anh em nếu mà anh em xem
livestream của tôi thì ừ từ thời đầu đến
bây giờ là tôi vẫn ở cái công ty hiện
tại tức là làm cũng là
hơn 5 năm rồi. 5 năm ừ hơn 5 năm sắp 6
năm rồi đấy. Thì
nghĩa là mình đang kiểu rất là kỳ cựu ở
trong công ty về công ty startup nữa.
Tôi là một trong những người vào đầu
tiên. Bây giờ người mà lâu nhất không
tính không tính cá sếp nhá. Cá sếp
founder rồi không tính nhá. Thì chắc là
có mỗi anh Tuấn bây giờ là còn trụ lại ở
công ty thôi. Còn những anh em mà gọi là
anh em J2 đúng không ạ?
Anh em Cam thì à cũng rơi dần rồi đấy.
Thì
nĩa là công ty rất rất lâu rồi đúng
không ạ? Đấy thì mình
kiểu nhưng mà tháng trước thì dự án của
tôi là cá sếp quyết định cắt giả.
Nghĩa là công ty tôi là lúc đầu là kiểu
đã đến một thời kỳ hoàng kim, tức là
công ty tôi về thương mại điện tử thời
kỳ hoàn kim là kiểu được dịch lại hoàng
kim cơ bởi vì mọi người chuyển qua mua
bán nhiều đấy nên là nó bung nổ lên các
thứ thứ xong rồi dự án một dự án là quá
triển vọng rồi nên là các sếp nghĩ hẳn
một cái dự án nữa để làm đấy hồi trước
là thị trường còn ngách ngách một tí tức
là chỉ Về POD là sản phẩm kiểu
POD là sản phẩm in ấn, sản phẩm may mặt
in ấn. Đấy, xong rồi mình chuyển qua hẳn
về group ship, tức là mọi sản phẩm các
thứ nó giống kiểu shopi đấy. thì à
dự án đấy lại không thành công bởi vì à
không biết tôi từ kể ông mấy ông chưa
thì nó là kiểu có một ông to nhất bọn
tôi làm ra thì ông ấy để phục vụ ông đấy
ông ấy đi bốc lịch rồi nên thành ra là
kiểu hai năm nay là cái dự án mới nó bị
ơ bé á
còn biết anh ở Tam Trinh ù
ờ cho mic Mic sớn chuyên e-commerce.
Đúng rồi, e-commerce không phải PP
Magento là Larel đấy. Mic nhỏ á. Đợi tôi
một tí xin lỗi trong cả đợi tí. Hình như
nó toàn tự động chỉnh chỉnh mic vậy. Đợi
tôi tí nhá. Đợi tí nhá.
À mic bây giờ dùng ma rồi. Thời để thời
đấy ăn gọi là bài trừ ma thì chúng ta
bây giờ quay ma rồi.
Cái mic input đâu nhỉ?
À đây input volume nó về. Alo ạ. Bây giờ
to hơn chưa ạ?
Alo alo.
To chưa?
Alo alo alo.
Được chưa? T cỡ chưa? Ơ sao mạng lại
chập trờn rồi.
Ok. Đấy thì đại khái thì cái dự án thứ
hai đấy à kiểu công ty bất ổn nên thành
ra là
à chính xác không phải công ty bất ổn mà
đại khái thì mất.
Chưa to á.
Sao lại chưa to nhỉ?
Hay là cái này lại chỉnh của anh rồi.
Anh nhớ hồi trước anh còn phải chạy một
cái tự động mỗi
mỗi lúc chạy một lần bởi vì nó cứ tự
động chỉnh lại cái input.
À đây.
Alo. Thế đủ to chưa ạ?
Alo alo alo
alo.
Đây input level volume tôi để level cao
nhất rồi đấy. Được chưa ạ?
Ok. Thì
t đây xem lại xem cái cái này tôi nhớ là
tôi đã chỉnh kiểu gọi như này nhỉ. Tôi
đã chỉnh cho nó
hồi trước tôi nhớ là cái mic này này.
Mic này từ thời đầu ấy là kẻo nó đủ to
nỗi luôn nói cái nó đỏ lòm ấy. Đấy tại
sao bây giờ nó bé nhỉ?
Không biết được. Ok. Thì
đang nói dở nó là kiểu cái dự án không
như mong muốn đúng không ạ? Kiểu rất
nhiều lúc và thế kể cả cho dù bạn có là
kiểu call member, kiểu dạng là thành
viên tiêu biểu, thành viên kiểu kỳ cựu
chăng nữa thì vẫn có thể kéo vẫn có thể
bị thay thế. Cho dù dù mình cố gắng hết
sức tròn vai à không tròn vai nó hơi
kiểu đôi khi là còn vượt cả
gọi là như là cái chức vụ của bản thân
mình đấy nhưng mà cuộc sống mà nên là
thành ra là tôi nghĩ là thế nên là mới
có cái gọi là chuyên mục này đấy chuyên
mục kiểu ngồi luyện bởi vì hồi đấy tôi
lại cảm thấy là nó đang khá là mong manh
rồi đấy còn gần đây thì nó còn bị mong
manh hơn nữ nữa khi mà 1 tháng trước thì
sếp quyết định cắt giảm cái dự án thì ờ
tôi á tôi cũng phải đi gửi một đống CV
một à kiểu
cũng gửi giải giác CV xong rồi kiểu
ông phải hiểu là kiểu hồi đấy tra PP ở
trên top CV chỉ mỗi hai công ty
cả nước chỉ có hai công công ty chứ
không phải là mỗi Hà Nội. Đấy, so về sau
tra thì ngày nào cũng tra thì có cuối
cùng cũng tìm được kiểu vài nơi để tuyển
à kiểu ứng tuyển đấy. Tôi tìm ở trên
Leon này có vẻ khả quan hơn theo kiểu là
có vẻ có nhiều kiểu người ta đăng lên
đấy nhiều hơn nhưng mà
người gọi mình đi thì thực ra là ừ mãi
về sau tôi mới có một một bên gọi thôi.
Bên đấy thực ra lại rất là gần nhà và nó
phải khớp rất rất nhiều cái
của tôi đang làm hiện tại thì mới được.
Tức là vừa khớp về công nghệ, vừa khớp
về nền tảng đấy, vừa khớp về cả kiểu
định hướng tương lai các thứ. Nó có vẻ
là cũng sáng sủa giống như cái đợt mà
hồi trước tôi từng phỏng vấn mà tôi từng
chia sẻ mấy ông đấy.
Nhưng mà lúc mà người ta gọi tôi lại là
kiểu gọi như này nhỉ? lại là lúc mà sếp
quyết định bảo tôi là là giữ tôi ở lại,
nghĩa là tôi sẽ được chuyển về dự án cũ
để làm. Đấy thì tôi cũng đầu tiên này
nghĩa là sếp vào là các giảm đây đúng
không? Trong một tuần đấy là kiểu lên
công ty kiểu chỉ ngồi tìm việc với kiểu
không biết phải làm gì ý. Đấy, xong rồi
à sang tuần sếp bảo là mới sếp mới thông
báo đấy thôi nhưng mà sếp bảo sang tuần
sếp mới chốt mà. Đấy,
thì sang tuần thì sếp bảo là sẽ giữ lại
các thứ thứ.
Thì lúc đấy ok cũng cảm thấy mừng bởi vì
bây giờ lúc đấy là chưa có ai chưa bên
nào gọi cả. Đấy, tôi còn tôi còn dùng AI
ngồi sửa lại một đống CV xong sửa lại
từng cái CV hợp từng cái mô tả công việc
một của từng công ty để mà gửi. Và AI
cũng như tôi cũng đều không muốn kiểu
chém gió trên CV của bản thân mình. Cho
dù rõ ràng là nhiều người bảo là chém
gió tầm 20 30% vẫn được mà. Mà tôi thì
kiểu cứ ghi trung thực trên đấy
nhưng mà tôi không biết được cro có biết
điều đấy không hay nghĩ là thằng này
chém gió
kiểu nhưng mà trung thực ở đây tức là
sao tức là tôi sẽ chỉ nói là tôi làm PP
hay là các thứ thứ những cái công nghệ
tôi từng làm chứ tôi không thể nổi à làm
sang ngôn ngữ khác các thứ thứ cho dù
cho dù tôi biết được là sếp tôi cũng bảo
là đến một cái trình độ kiểu bây giờ em
đi ứng tuyển senior mà đặc biệt có AI
bây giờ thực ra là người ta sẽ không hỏi
về công nghệ hay không hỏi về code nhiều
nữa. Người ta hỏi về tư duy lập trình tư
duy nhiều thứ khác hơn đấy nhưng mà tôi
vẫn chỉ ghi kiểu thì mình làm đến đâu
mình biết lần đấy thôi đúng không ạ thì
nó sẽ
thì đúng là nó sẽ bị kén trọng bởi vì
bây giờ PP còn tuyển mấy đâu đúng không
ạ? Đấy à
xong rồi. Ừ. Nói chung là tôi cũng vẫn
dự định là mình sẽ phải ngồi học luyện
để mà
không biết được kiểu sẽ thế nào đấy và
đặc biệt là ờ
cái việc mà tôi quyết định ở lại. Hôm
đấy tôi phỏng vấn bên kia có vẻ rất là
thành công nhưng tôi vẫn tự từ từ chối
bên đấy bảo là em a bởi vì em sắp lập
gia đình đấy đầ tiên xin thông báo mấy
ông nữa đó là kiểu tôi à tôi gọi là
nhiều tôi thường hay nói thì mấy ông
không biết mấy ông từng biết vụ đây
không tôi luôn hứa là tầm à
cuối cuối năm 29 tuổi tức là năm nay của
tôi tôi tính tôi là là theo lịch dương
nhá đấy
không tính tuổi mụ hay các thứ thì cuối
năm nay là tôi sẽ lấy vợ đây các thứ.
Thế thì
tôi sắp lận lập gia đình nên thành ra
tôi nghĩ là tôi sẽ phải ổn định. Ít nhất
là vẫn đang giữ được công việc đã. Không
thể bây giờ nhảy sang công ty mới rồi
bắt đầu kiểu bập bõm mọi thứ được đúng
không ạ? Đấy nghĩa là mình tạm ổn định
công việc
sau đó thì tính tiếp.
Và bây giờ cũng có nhiều thứ phải lo
phết. Ví dụ ngay ngày hôm nay tôi còn
ngồi cãnh nhau với vợ với cái vụ làm
thiếp cưới tôi có rất nhiều ý tưởng phải
không ạ? M không biết là tôi có nhiều ý
tưởng kiểu như nào đâu. Đặc biệt kết hợp
với AI nữa ui nó kiểu giúp cho tôi thỏa
mãn được cái sự ý tưởng cũng như là rất
nhiều cái không dù rất nhiều ông có thể
chửi tôi kiểu phomo hay là rất nhiều
thứ. Ví dụ là kiểu dạng là AI slop à đấy
vân vân tất cả kiểu lạm dụng AI xong rồi
kiểu làm ra những cái sản phẩm tồi bằng
ai ấy n tôi không quan tâm tôi kiểu chữ
quan tâm kiểu
vì vốn trước là tôi rất muốn làm nhiều
thứ nhưng mà bởi vì không có
không có thời gian cũng như là lười hay
rất nhiều yếu tố mà kiểu không làm được
đấy hoặc đây là không năng khiếu chẳng
hạn ví dụ giả sử không năng khiếu Mỹ
thẩm mỹ, mỹ thuật mấy không ạ? Nhiều cái
tôi thấy đẹp mà mọi người kiểu cái này
xấu mà tôi thì thấy rồi kiểu nhưng mà nó
kiểu nó tiện này hoặc là nó cũng có gì
nó đẹp mà cho đến khi người ra chỉ tôi
thấy tôi phải biết được nó xấu thật đấy.
Nghĩa là ý tôi là thế. Nghĩa là với tôi
AI bây giờ nó đã là
đủ để quá đủ để dùng đấy. Tapi gần đây
còn con GBT mới ra nữa. Uầy tôi cảm thấy
với tôi thế quá đủ để mà dùng các thứ
thứ thôi. Không quay gì không không
sitting gì ở đây cả nhá. Nếu mà shing
thì bây giờ tôi phải để cái mã ở đây nó
mới hợp lý này.
Đấy. Nhưng mà đại khái là thế. Nghĩa là
à
tuy là 2 tháng qua tôi không livestream
đúng không ạ? Mà trong 2 tháng qua công
việc, mối quan hệ này xong rồi cả tư duy
tôi cảm thấy là trưởng thành hơn. Ví dụ
riêng về công việc gần đây là tôi a
dùng ai để mà đây như là vẫn dùng ai
thôi nhưng mà ý à dùng ai một cách triệt
để hơn rất nhiều để mà làm được rất
nhiều thứ khác nữa
mà cảm thấy vui ý. Mấy không ạ? Thấy vui
ấy. Hồi trước là tôi từng thích đóng góp
cho cộng đồng các thứ, làm những cái
miễn phí cho cộng đồng các thứ nhưng bây
giờ còn được kiểu
gọi như là được trân trọng. Bởi vì ví dụ
mấy ông nhìn thấy hiện tại tôi đang dùng
là thằng Cuso đúng không ạ? Cus đấy.
Cuso này của tôi được bên cus tài trợ
đấy. Dùng từ tài trợ nó không biết đúng
không? Đại khái hôm đấy gần đây các công
ty nó ganh đua cạnh tranh cũng hơi thiếu
lành mạnh một tí bằng cách kiểu nó bảo
tôi nhớ cái bài đăng đấy nó bảo là à bạn
chỉ còn chụp lại cái a lịch sử và bạn đã
hủy cái sử dụng AI ở bên khác đấy gửi
mail chụp lại mail này chụp lại hóa đơn
các thứ gửi bọn tôi. Và tôi sẽ cho bạn
là Pro Plus tức là 60 đô đấy
là sử dụng trong 1 tháng đấy.
Nhưng đúng là tôi gần đây tôi hủy à tôi
hủy Chat TVT thật nhưng là không phải
hủy bởi vì chán sử dụng nó. Tôi công ty
tôi cấp cloud nhá nhưng mà tôi vẫn mua
charity Plus bỏ túi à tiền túi bỏ ra bởi
vì tôi cảm thấy ạ dùng cloud thôi đôi
khi không đủ và dùng từ không đủ không
đúng cloud ở công ty dùng tương đối rất
là thoải mái nhưng nói là à tôi đôi khi
có nhiều cái là kiểu tôi cảm thấy là thứ
nhất là tôi vẫn chat với chat TV hàng
ngày nên tôi muốn độ cá nhân hóa nó cao.
Thứ hai đó là rất nhiều cái tôi thường
hay dùng song song là cloud vẫn gọi đến
codex để mà kiểu kiểm tra chéo nhau. Đấy
là cả
cloud không sinh ảnh thì dùng codex thì
sinh ra ảnh vân vân làm tài liệu mọi thứ
cũng bằng codex cũng xịn hơn này. Thì
tại bây giờ gần đây cóch ra cái
à conra rất ngon mỗi tội là
rất nguồn token thật sự đặc biệt là nếu
mà tài khoản plus đấy thì
đại khái thì tại sao tự à hơi dài dòng
tí nghĩa đại khái thì tôi hủy cho cpt
bởi vì tôi gần đây tôi đóng góp rất
nhiều cho các open xc ở trên gitub
Xong rồi tôi có thử tự thử kiểu gửi form
để mà xin cái chatt kiểu được tài trợ
bởi Open AI ấy. Rồi được duyệt. Thế là
bây giờ tôi có chat TV. Đấy nhìn chung
cái đợt đợt hồi trước tôi vẫn nhớ là
Open AI cũng chơi cái trò ở trên mạng xã
hội X á là kiểu là
à đăng đăng status khen
à chavity và chê cloud thì cũng sẽ được
100 đô credit vào trong tài khoản. Nói
chung là thỉnh thoảng cũng có mấy kiểu
bựa phết. Đấy tôi cũng được cả vụ đấy
cơ. Đấy đại khái bây giờ tôi được 6
tháng cho GPT Pro cái đấy á cái tài
khoản CHT Pro là gấp năm lần Plus à thì
nó sẽ là
100 đô mỗi tháng đấy. Ôi mất mã
đấy thì thế nên là tôi mới phải hủy cái
chat plus bởi vì nó lại chơi cái trò là
kiểu
phải hủy hết cái submion của cái gói này
đợi khi hết sạch đã thì mình mới kiểu
nâng lên được. Đấy nên thành ra tôi có
cái mail kia và từ cái mailở đây tôi lại
xin được cái
tài khoản pro này cũng tiện phết. Nhưng
đại khái hôm nay dài dòng thì khá là
nhiều ủi 20 phút ngồi dài dòng thì hôm
nay tôi định à
vẫn sẽ có ngồi học không phải mỗi tâm sự
không tôi sẽ ngồi học tiếp bài hôm
trước. Hôm trước cũng đương nhiên là đề
cập về design button đúng không ạ? Thực
ra là
thực ra là chuẩn là tôi định soạn lại
một tí cái bài hôm đấy bởi vì là hôm
trước đi phỏng vấn,
hôm trước đi phỏng vấn thì người ta cũng
hỏi lại tôi khá nhiều về thiết kế design
design không phải không phải design
button mà design system đúng rồi là
thiết kế hệ thống. Hôm trước người ta
khỏi tôi khá nhiều về cái đấy bởi vì hồi
trước là tôi luôn tự tin về khoản là tôi
làm back end kiểu call backend ở công ty
đấy. Nhưng mà người ta hỏi kéo người ta
cũng hỏi nhiều câu cũng cũng
gọi là bẫy phết không phải à dùng từ bẫy
không đúng nghĩa họ họ thực sự hỏi những
cái câu mà có họ đang gặp phải ở trên
công ty ví dụ ở đền hình là bây giờ gửi
tận à
kiểu bắn 3000 3 4000 request một lúc và
mỗi lần thì cập nhật tận trăm đến nghìn
cái sản phẩm nghìn var các thứ thứ thì
nên xử lý mọi thứ như
Đấy các thứ th các bài toán thực tế mà
họ đang gặp phải ở trên Shopify. Đấy thì
tôi hôm đấy là đúng là kiểu chưa chưa
làm trường hợp kiểu đấy bao giờ chưa giờ
bình thường là mình có thể làm kiểu bằng
cập nhật bằng create nhưng mà không có
chuyện là kiểu bằng kiểu dạng đồng bộ
các thứ thứ thế cũng chưa làm hoặc là họ
hỏi sâu thêm về thiết kế hệ thống của
công ty hiện tại.
Đúng rồi, nó thiết kế hệ thống này.
Ừ.
Ừ ừ anh nói nhầm ấy nó sion design chứ
không phải là design button
đấy. Đại khái thì mình sẽ quay lại bài
hôm đây nhá.
Đây có hẳn một thư mục cưới riêng luôn.
System này sa
ơ hôm trước mới làm đến bài
ngày hai à như sai sai đúng không? Tôi
xem lại nào.
Hôm trước tận ngày 4 rồi mà.
rồi
ơ hôm trước mấy ngày hai thật này.
Ờ ok không sao
đấy hôm nay mình sẽ à
dùng hẳn JVT son đấy.
Dư giảm mà th ạ. Không biết dư lắm
không. Xem lại cái con Coron này tôi đã
tiêu được bao nhiêu rồi này.
Đến ngày à 24 ngày nữa
dùng 138 à. Ok. Có vẻ còn dư đấy. Súng
hẳn cao đi. Đấy.
Soạn cho tôi đây. B
đấy.
Nhưng kiểu lạm dụng. AI. Tôi xin lỗi mấy
ông. Xin lỗi về gì nhở?
Tốn điện, tốn nước, tốn rất nhiều cái.
Rất xin lỗi.
Tạ tắt bớt ng
cái gì? Hi sir. What are we studying
today? Em chào anh. Hôm nay học gì thế
anh? Uầy
cái nó dịch tiếng Anh kiểu dịch định
phết từ cái câu
hát nay
thế mà nó còn kiểu hiểu được kiểu thành
hôm nay
này. Hi sir. What are we studying today?
Antiravity cũng ok nhưng nó đần quá.
Tôi mất niềm tin lắm. Mất niềm tin vào.
Tôi đã từng hy vọng rất rất nhiều rất
rất nhiều vào trong
Google. Nhưng không, Google lừa chúng ta
anh em ạ. Google lừa lắm.
Bay mất.
Đợi tí nào.
Không cần xem problem. Không cần xem.
Cái gì
này? Kí à
không cần xem
chỉ cần ngắn gọn này thôi.
Xem live toàn bị đọc mà không trả lời em
à. Hả? Chúng ta hôm nay học thiết kế hệ
thống cái gì nhỉ?
Ờ
>> xem live toàn bị delay, toàn xoay không?
Tôi nghĩ là do mạng tôi hay sao ấy. Kiểu
vừa rồi vừa kiểu thỉnh thoảng báo thành
kiểu dạng là sóng yếu hay gì đó. Không
biết là có phải mạng tôi hay mạng mấy
ông không nhưng mà của tôi báo tôi sóng
yếu
xong rồi thỉnh thoảng bây giờ thành
nét nhưng mà tôi nghĩ là bị tình hình
chung
chung cũng pi pu
gọi là như nào nhỉ giống idol ở một
khoản nào Đó
>> đấy.
>> P
ok bạn.
Ừ, đáng lẽ là xong tôi sẽ ghi ok đấy.
À đúng rồi.
Đấy, chuẩn là còn phải ừ
đây, vừa nãy tôi định khoe khoe mấy ông
mà dùng tôi dùng cái con agent này. Tôi
đáng e chuẩn còn phải cái rock bot nữa
cơ nhưng mà kiểu không biết dùng con
boss trong việc gì về thừa token. N
không biết dùng về việc gì luôn đấy.
Ô cái gì này th sư đi. Đấy thì tôi con
con này có hai cái hai phết conent riêng
này để mà chỉ đơn giả là chat thôi.
Không cần đọc code cả đôi khi không cần
quan tâm code nó trông như nào.
Mạng pi đường truyền diễng xà lách
>> đúng pi lúc mà livestream kiểu không
biết chơi game hay không nhưng mà
livestream kiểu để bán hàng thì công
nhận là đường truyền xịn đấy. Anh dùng
ma gì ạ? Anh dùng ma4 em ạ.
mua từ năm ngoái công nhận đầu tư xứng
đáng đúng hôm ngày mưa gió
kiểu hôm đấy kiểu ở nhà đang ở nhà thứ
là có máy rồi nhưng máy tính cùi khó
chịu ấy xong rồi mưa gió nên là làm
online ấy tôi đặtet
luôn một con m súng
và nó xứng đá bởi vì
ngoài việc là dùng được mọi thứ ra không
nói. Đang nói là đấy bây giờ mấy ông
thấy giá máy M tăng đúng không? Bây giờ
tính ra cái con này của tôi rồi bán đi
còn có lời
ơ mạng yếu thôi xong rồi.
Cái mạng stream có vấn đề ấy chứ. Chứ
còn tôi chat mọi thứ ở đây thấy có vấn
đề gì không nhỉ? Đấy tạo bao này.
Đây câu hỏi này.
Review này.
Thiết kế một hệ thống tương tự base
spin.
Tại sao nó có cái base spin ở đây nhỉ?
P spin này là nó giống cái
notep nhỉ?
Thầy còn quẩy Zota 2 không
ông? Ông thấy đang dùng máy gì không?
Giọng thì nghe nghe ổn nhưng mà hình thì
mất.
Ờ nghe giống Pu Pi đấy. Pi như giọng
cũng còn mất luôn đúng không? C mất cả
hai đ
anh nhớ xem cái quả cắt v bút cười
người ta là bây giờ cứ ngồi gọi điện cho
anh Độ sao bị cắt
thiết kế một hệ thống tương tự PIN
người nhận đường dẫn có thể xem lại nội
dung đã lưu
ngày tạo có thể chọn thời gian hết hạn
Khi hết hạn
hệ thống cần hỗ trợ.
Ừ ừ nó cũng giống g đúng không? Giống
gặc là notepad. Anh hình dung ra notepad
hơn bởi vì nó chỉ là một cái đoạn văn
bản thôi. Không cần phải dạng ma down
hay một cái gì cả. Nó giống part mà cũng
kiểu copy luôn cái đường dẫn đấy để mà
gửi người ta.
Đúng rồi. Hệ thống đọc lớn hơn lượng ghi
đấy. Thế nên anh đang nghĩ là sẽ dùng
cách
chắc chắn nên dùng cách để mà tránh việc
là truy vấn vào DB quá nhiều, read nhiều
cần hỗ trợ nội dung công khai hoặc riêng
tư hoặc và giới hạn kích thước mỗi đoạn
văn bản.
Ừ.
Phần nào? Phần trả lời nhỉ?
Nhỡ hình như cứ trả lời thẳng đây. Trả
lời.
Ừ.
Thực ra anh ỉ vẫn đang chưa hình dung
được rõ là kiểu
nên thiết kế cái gì đầu tiên mình ấy cứ
kiểu từ trước nay thực tế mà nói thôi
công ty chắc là chỉ thiết kế database
với kiểu cách tổ chức code hay mọi thứ
như nào chưa chưa chưa đến mức độ là về
hạ tầng hay kiểu dạng là đặt máy chủ mọi
thứ như nào xong rồi dùng mấy cái a công
nghệ gì, dùng cái dùng phần cứng hay mọi
thứ như nào, thậm chí là phần cứng phải
bao nhiêu, bao nhiêu ghi và bao nhiêu GB
vân vân vân thì đúng
chưa được kiểm soát cái điều đấy bao giờ
để mà biết rõ cái điều này.
Chắc là chỉ dừng ở việc là
ừ tôi sẽ thiết kế
liệu là có
Ừ
lưu chữ và truy sất nội dung xử lý nội
dung hết hạn.
Thực tế là cái này chỉ có một bảng chủ
yếu nhỉ? Không
à đâu chắc cũng nó là hai bảng. Có ví dụ
hai bảng đi
user này và
đăng là post đi đây chẳng hạn. Thế đúng
không?
Thì post lại có thêm là ID này. UID
chẳng hạn.
link
sẽ bằng à ví dụ là page pin.com
uid chẳng hạn.
Đấy.
Đương nhiên là
thực ra là nếu mà để công khai ấ
là vẫn sẽ có cái khái niệm là tuy là
công em để một cái link công khai nghĩa
là thực tế là còn tùy trường hợp là nó
có được kiểu Google index nà nó hay
không. Tuy là nhiều link link công khai
mà Google nó còn cấm cho robot vào để mà
kiểu đánh index hay mọi thứ cho nó nhá.
Tức là link công khai là ai cũng vào xem
được đúng không? Nhưng thực tế là phải
có người có được link thì mới vào xem
được. Đấy, kiểu thế cơ đấy. Kiểu không
có nghĩa là công khai kiểu công khai
ngoài toàn bộ internet đấy. Thế nên là
đôi khi là UID kiểu mình phải
ngoài việc viết theo kiểu là nó dài theo
kiểu tránh bị trùng ấy phải khó đoán,
phải dài ra cơ để tránh việc là có người
ngồi chạy, ngồi chạy kiểu brot for để
lấy lấy hết toàn bộ những cái link công
khai của mình chẳng hạn. Đấy. Vì rõ ràng
là mình tạo một cái link công khai code
là bởi vì là mình không muốn
mình không muốn quá phức tạp nhưng mà
bản chất là mình cứ nghĩ đang nghĩ đơn
giản là mình copy cái link đấy rồi cho
bạn bè mình người khác cũng không biết
được đâu. Rồi tự nhiên bây giờ thấy cái
link mình nhăn nhản ở đâu ông nào cũng
cầm được thì nó lại đôi khi nó lại không
nó hơi nhạy cảm thấy kiểu thế. Thế tôi
tôi nghĩ là thế nhá. Thích thì tôi ghi
thêm ở trong này cũng được tỏ vẻ mình
chuyên nghiệp.
Cũng cần tạo rõ link public
công khai
là
ai cũng có thể
tìm thấy và xem được.
Thậm chí
đánh index robot
vào được
hay
là link kiểu khó đoán id
và gần như
code để usơ lời
nhập à lời Hương link
mất khẩu phức tạp
nhưng chỉ người có được link mới biết
từ đó kết luận
được độ phức tạp của Linh.
Nhưng mà tôi bảo rồi đôi khi là tôi đi
và hơi bị tiểu tiết vụn vặn cái này quá.
Cho dù rõ ràng người ta đang nói về
thiết kế hệ thống á, mình vẫn phải nhìn
khái quát trước xong rồi mới đến cái chi
tiết. Nhưng mà tôi đôi khi là tôi kiểu
cứ nhìn vào một cái tôi nghĩ là tôi kiểu
nảy ra một ý tưởng kiểu rất là chi tiết
một cái gì đó ấy.
Tôi vừa rồi tôi còn vừa nghĩ là không
biết là cách tư duy đấy có giống kiểu
Việt Thảo không. Vịt Thảo là kiểu đôi
khi là nhìn vào đấy nảy ý tưởng hack
được chẳng hạn. Đấy kiểu hacker man à
kiểu thế tôi nghĩ có gần giống thế nghĩa
có một tí liên quan bảo mật liên quan
đến kiểu vân vân ấy đấy nó hơi tiểu tiết
thì trong trường hợp này thì mình cần
nghĩ làm nếu mà làm nhanh trước thì nó
sẽ chỉ đơn giản là
à
nếu mà chỉ có public với private giả sử
thế thì nó sẽ là à
thường nó sẽ
ví dụ is public chẳng hạn đấy và kèm
theo password đấy chẳng hạn đúng không?
Nhưng hồi trước tôi từng nói tôi từng
đọc một cái này là đôi khi hai cái hai
cột ấy mà nó còn bị phụ thuộc lẫn nhau
thì nó bị buồn cười. Tức là chỉ là
nếu mà nó public như nó vừa có password
thì sao? Ông hiểu tôi không ạ? Đấy,
public nh password. Đấy.
Thì rõ ràng đôi khi là chỉ cần một cột
password là đủ. Nhưng mà cột đấy nếu mà
chỉ có mỗi cột password ấy thì nó lại
không không
thể hiện rõ được cái ý đồ của cái của
cái link đấy là public hay là private.
Nghĩa là bạn phải tự phải nhìn vào cái
đấy và tự kiểu suy luận ra nó public
public hay là private ấy. Đấy ông ông
hiểu ý tôi. Đấy. Nhưng mà nếu mà để hai
cột như hiện tại như này chẳng hạn thì
nó lại kiểu phụ thuộc lẫn nhau. Tức là
bây giờ tôi đang để nó private xong tôi
để vào password xong tự nhiên tôi chuyển
nó thành lên public thì rõ ràng password
phải xóa đi đúng không? Đấy kiểu thế ông
ông hiểu ý tôi không?
Đấy.
Hay là cứ mặc định PPIC là không cần
phải nhập mật khẩu thì cái cồn mật khẩu
xóa đi hay giữ hay là cứ mặc định là
PUIC là không nhập mật khẩu nên PIC à dù
có mật khẩu hay không thì kệ nó. Thì
thành ra là cái trường đấy nó đang thành
phản tác dụng đúng không? Đấy,
tôi đang suy nghĩ
về hai code này vì có vẻ nó liên quan
tới nhau.
Đấy,
lưu lượng tăng cao. Đây có đề cập
ờ
đây ở đây
có đề cập lưu lượng
tăng cao. Làm thế nào để biết
hay chỉ là phóng đoán
mặc định à.
À theo tôi hiểu
thì
à nếu đọc nhiều hơn ghi thì hạn chế truy
vấn vào DB
có thể
dùng cách
nhưng và
khi người dùng thay đổi kiểu
trạng thái này của link thì
xóa cách
có sẽ kết
biến nhưng lại phụ thuộc
vào câu hỏi
trên
là chưa nắm rõ
lưu lượng thế nào nếu có thêm
bản lưu
>> tâm suất
truy cập link thì tôi thấy bảng đó nên
phù hợp
để thống kê
và không
nên nằm trong MQ
quá nhiều.
À đúng rồi. Cái link quan trọng nhất ở
đây nó sẽ là dụ là context nội dung bên
trong đúng không? Đấy là user ID đấy.
U đấy gì? Update đấy chẳng hạn. Đấ đấy.
Ừ.
Xử lý nội dung hết hạn.
À đây còn expired đấy.
Và cách cũng tự hết hạn
khi
có đi
expired
kèm theo khóa link.
Nếu mà khóa thì tôi nghĩ là như thế nó
sẽ có những trạng thái a
ừ
nó sẽ có một cú riêng
thay đổi
status
kiểu mặc định là grap này,
open này, close chẳng hạn. Giả sử thế
tôi đang nghĩ thế thôi đấy.
Ừ.
Xử lý nội dung hết hạn mở rộng khi
ứng phó
khi một phần hệ thống gặp lỗi. Ở đây
nhắc
à vì có nhắc đến
một phần hệ thống
cặp lỗi tức là
có thể là
một trong các chu
có vấn đề thì để tránh
yếu đó
Một là cơ sở
dữ liệu phân tán à
load ba lần
sinh
nói cái này cho vui tôi không phải biết
cái này chưa biết làm cái này bao giờ
chắc là nó vẫn là chia chia chia kiểu
dạng là để tránh quá tải trong một cái
server thôi nhỉ chắc Thế
tôi chưa biết
chưa làm đoán thế
tí cần giải thích thêm
đâ cứ nói rõ ràng mình đang dùng người
ai mà mà đi phỏng vấn thì tôi nghĩ tôi
cũng sẽ thật thà đấy thôi. Thế tôi bảo
tôi đi phỏng vấn tôi không chém gió đâu.
Đây. Ừm,
chủ thích thuật ngữ này đang hơi bị à
cũng cho thuật ngữ lắm nên thôi không
sao.
Thế không nhỉ? Mấy ông có bổ sung góp ý
gì không?
Tự nhiên tôi lại muốn kiểu chia trêu.
Tôi muốn nói kìa. Sau rồi hả? các chuyên
giá
mấy ông có cân bổ sung gì không ạ?
Ok. Có vẻ không cần bổ sung gì cả.
Ừ. Chạy thử ấy nhỉ?
Lịch sử đi.
Tôi đã làm phát thảo trả lời tương đối
xong.
Bạn
Painp không? Cái này cũng chưa phải là
một cái giải quyết kiểu pinpoint cho
lắm.
Nó nó chỉ là kiểu
nếu pin nhất nó vừa đề cập thì theo tôi
là kiểu nó sẽ có lúc kiểu đến ngưỡng quá
tải thì và lúc lỗi sẽ nên như nào? Còn
pinpo ở đây nghĩa là
trừ khi ý em anh anh hiểu cái từ pin
point em đang nói nhưng mà phải ý anh à
nếu mà dịch thô từ pin point ra tức là
một cái vấn đề mà người dùng gặp phải
đúng không?
Nhiều người dịch pinpoint là theo kể là
nhu cầu người dùng đấy. Rõ là nhu cầu
cần cái gì thì rõ ràng mình chỉ cần một
cái trang đơn giản bình thường một cái
notốep mà đúng không? Rất là code đơn
giản như nói. Còn nếu mà pimp là một cái
vấn đề mà người dùng đau đáu, người dùng
cần đấy và thậm chí là ngoài kia đeo
khoer thôi thì rõ ràng là đúng chả có
một pin point nào đây cả. Đấy vấn đệ nó
không quá phức tạp.
Đấy nên là
ừ thì rõ ràng nó vẫn chỉ quay lại câu
chuyện là
kiểu xem chắc là có mỗi mấy câu này được
thôi.
Chấm xem
anh nhớ là hồi trước anh đâu bảo nó làm
soạn luôn cái này không nhỉ?
À my solution trong này ạ.
Lỗi thôi.
Đây chuyển sang solution chấm. Ok. hợp
lý hơn đấy.
Chuyển hộ tí
accept button
cốc lội.
sẽ cứu trực tiếp
tổ chức lock up nhanh quản lý TTRL và
bảo vệ hệ thống cấ đ viên viễn học
dot à kiểu thế
tạm mã chia sẻ duy nhất cho mỗi nội dung
này đọc nội dung độ chạy thấp và độ sẵn
sàng cao tự động vô hiệu hóa và
nếu mà theo uid thì rõ ràng là truy vắn
mọi thứ rất là nhanh đúng không vấn đề
gì
nó primary
còn
đây id duy nhất c thành mã ngắn metadata
mà nội dung
sorry
ừ đúng rồi thực cả nếu mà chia nếu mà
chia kiểu
nhiều hệ thống như vừa rồi đề cập thì nó
sẽ bị nhược điểm là
khó tận dụng lại cách mày không biết cái
vụ đấy không?
Tức là kiểu ví dụ là kiểu mỗi một quốc
gia một con ma chủ đi đúng không ạ? Đấy
thì rõ ràng là nếu mà giả sử mà biết đâu
đấy mà chia sẻ cái
link đấy cho nước ngoài thì rõ không tận
dụng kch này chẳng hạn vì không chọn đấy
nút cái máy chủ vân vân đấy thậm chí là
mình còn đang chia đang gọi là
đấy đề cập là kiểu cân bằng tải chưa
chia chia ra mà chia làm sang máy trụ
khác hay vân vân vân
Cái bất đồng bộ nội dung thì anh vừa nãy
anh định đề cập thì không không có bất
đồng bộ vì vì à kiểu gì cơ sở liệu phân
tán tức là mình kiểu gì mình vẫn sẽ t
kiểu
mấy con nó sẽ gần như là bản xa của nhau
ấy.
Anh
xài tra chưa ạ? Anh có dung rồi. Cứ mỗi
lần anh hỏi nó vài câu là anh hết sư
dung lượng. À qua đấy.
Chấm bài 4 năm
anh Tôi vẫn nhớ là hôm đầu chấm là 4 hôm
đầu chấm 4,5. Lần này lại 4,5
chôn mô hình quyền truy cập
ui asum từ này không biết luôn có rất
nhiều từ khóa không biết
chị ký thế lâu
Bài có những chức giác đúng về mô hình
đu
đọc nhiều cách thời gian hết hạn và tách
dữ liệu thống kê khỏi máy web vẫn là ghi
chú khám phá vấn đề nhiều hơn là thiết
kế mở đóng quá trình ở mức phỏng vấn
senior bài chưa đủ
assumption là
Assumption là gì?
U
tí tôi phải ngồi traumtion là gì?
Trong này as thôi tưởng tôi cần lắm tạm
dụng lắm tôi hỏi cha JVT đây.
Ơ ch máy này chưa login à?
Ê câu kia dịch tiếng Anh ra. D please
enlighten me. Khai sáng à? Hay à? Ui câu
hay quá.
Đợ tí tôi cho mấy ông xem chat GVT của
tôi nha. Đấy, quý lắm mới cho xem. Đấy.
Đấy, tôi tạo hẳn một cái learning đấy.
Cái GBT riêng nên là in cứ nhắn vào đây
để nó giải thích.
Giả định
giả định nói mẹ giả định
thỉnh thoảng cái tiếng Anh khó chịu vãi.
Anh lại nhớ qua hôm nay cái agent kit
cái cloud kit ý kiểu có những mức độ
kiểu output nó trả ra AI trả ra mình ấy.
Kiểu từ
newbe kiểu kiểu thế tức là kiểu nontech
đấy không biết gì công nghệ đến junior
middle senior xong rồi team lead xong
rồi god mode đấy god mode mà theo kiểu
là
nó chỉ cho mình code thôi không giải
thích cái gì cả đấy thì cái này đang
giải thích vẫn là chắc là theo cái kiểu
tầm ở giữa giữa là sino đấy chứ Chứ anh
thấy mid đồ với junio là nó bắt đầu giải
thích nó không có mấy cái từ khóa này
đâu à nó sẽ ngồi giải thích lại cái từ
khóa đấy
đúng không đọc lý do chọn storage cách
mở rộng
lý do chọn storage ừ đúng rồi vừa chưa
đề cập việc dùng database nào đấy nhận
xét nhanh đặt đúng câu hỏi công khai có
nghĩa là lập trình mục tình kiếm hay
phải xác
Điểm tốt nhất của bài. Uầy, tôi nói một
câu vơ đấy. Tôi nghĩ là mềm tiểu tiết
cuối cùng nó điểm tốt nhất tôi nhìn thấy
ạ. Điểm yếu chính là dừng ở câu hỏi là
tích công nghệ. Sợ liệu nó chưa giải
thích dữ liệu được phân vùng ra sao, bản
sao lỗi chuyển đổi như thế nào và
request đang xử lý sẽ ra sao. Ồ shit.
Điểm đúng nhận ra phải làm rõ mô hình
truy cập trước khi quyết định độ dài và
khả năng đoán của mã chia sẻ. Nhận ra hệ
thống đọc nhiều hơn ghi nên cách có thể
dùng giảm tải database liên hệ TTL của
cách và expire đã đúng. Cách không nên
sống lâu hơn thời gian hiệu lực.
Nghĩ đến xóa cách thì trạng thái thay
đổi là đúng hướng nếu page được phép cập
nhật.
không muốn tăng bộ đếm chuy cập là hợp
lý lượng sử
đúng rồi
lại bắt đầu nghĩ đến máy chủ và loại bỏ
điểm lỗi đơn điểm lỗi đơn cái này thỉnh
thoảng tôi nghĩa là có nhiều cái nó
không nên dịch cái này nó sẽ là single
po
single po
single failer coin đấy. Không biết mày
có biết từ đấy không? Single failer
coin tức là
dùng kiểu nó giống như là kiểu ngón chân
của Akilit ấ kiểu điểm yếu duy nhất kiểu
chỉ cần chọc vào đấy mọi thứ nó sẽ đủ
sụp ấ đấy
đấy nó kiểu kiểu thế kểu không nên dồn
hết
tất cả trứng và một giỏ đúng không đấy
nếu mà có vấn đề gì thì nó làm đổ sập
hết đấy. Uầy, xem view ở đây tận 2200
view. Uầy,
sao hôm nay đột biến thế nhỉ? Tôi bỏ qua
việc là mấy ông ở lại bao nhiêu ấy nhưng
mà kiểu quá đột biến ấy. Có gì vậy?
Bình thường view của tôi là tầm 300 view
này, 400 view này. Có hôm lên được 1000
thôi. Ừ cũng có hôm lên tận 2000. hai
ngày nhưng mà kiểu
hôm đấy ngày buổi đầu ấy chắc là mọi
người còn kiểu hóng hóng tí
lâu lắm hồi lên được 2000 view đây còn
gọi là gọi là như nào
bình thường là cái lượt view kia nó tăng
ấy bởi vì là kiểu mấy ông a có thể nhiều
ông không on ngay tại thời điểm đấy thì
mấy ông kiểu mấy ngày sau vào xem này
hay gì gì đó kiểu mấy ông có xem lại ý
tôi thấy tỉ lệ xem lại còn 50% cơ. Tức
là tức là kiểu mấy ông không xem trực
tiếp mà mấy ông sẽ xem vào một cái thời
điểm thích hợp ấy. Dụ đây lên 2000 view
ngay tại trong a
nãy giờ chưa đến một tiếng.
Video này lên đến nổi 3000 3000 view
mình sẽ comeback. Đấy
tôi định hôm nay là livestream có lý do.
Hôm nay vợ tôi
dùng từ bỏ ra hơi quá đáng. Vợ tôi hôm
nay đi tập thể dục thể thao nên tôi ở
nhà bình thường thì tôi hồi trước là
giống như anh em bảo là có thể chơi game
hoặc làm gì khác nhưng mà tôi cảm thấy
phải hơn 1 năm rồi tôi không chơi game.
Thế bây giờ tôi cũng dùng ai ngồi làm
việc ngồi lướt mạng xã hội cho vui thôi
thì tôi nghĩ là ừ bây giờ sẽ thứ năm
hàng tuần mình sẽ ngồi livestream. Có vẻ
là đó là một cái hay.
Đúng rồi. Bạn đi đánh cầu lông mà. Đấy.
Tôi thì à tôi cũng thích mấy các môn thể
thao đấy nhưng mà bạn ấy đánh ở bên mạng
nhà bạn đấy là ở bên a hôm nay còn về
tận à Yông Hà Đông.
Bạn ấy thì ở bên Mễ Trì về y ông Hà Đông
ấy vẫn còn tương đối gọi là gần gần với
bạn đấy. Cứ tôi đang ở đại học Y tôi
đây cho mình mọi người xem quá à xem thì
biết luôn địa chỉ nhà thì nó không nên
lắm
đâu. Nhưng mà đây tôi thử đo nhà tôi với
bên bạn đấy là 18 cây
đây kiểu nhỉ 18 cây. Úi giồii
đấy.
À đâu nhầm 11 cây. Nói nhầm nói nhầm 28
phút 11 cây.
Nhưng mà
lúc đi về xong rồi hoặc là lúc ăn cơm
xong hơi ngại đi xa. Thế
sai trời bắt đầu vào thu rồi mấy không
ạ. Đấy bắt đầu kiểu mưa gió lạnh lẽo.
Cái này đúng nhỉ? Gõ lại phát nữa nào.
Nhớ đúng
đây. Single point of fellow à. Đấy.
Đây nếu mà nó hỏng toàn bộ hệ thống hoặc
một chức năng là nó sẽ ngừng hoạt động.
Chưa chốt functional
requirement.
có cho tạo ẩn danh không? Page có sửa
được không? Có sửa mà. Có cho sửa mà
chẳng qua không đề cập đấy chứ. Kích
thước tối đa đội trễ đọc.
À mình đôi khi là mình nếu mà làm theo
kiểu tôi hướng đến tôi không hướng đến
đơn giản đâu mấy không ạ? Một là
lý tưởng thì sẽ là
à gì nhỉ? Quên tên à?
design architect đấy, solution architect
đấy. Xong rồi về sau sẽ lên được cái
ngưỡng là product owner. Đấy, kiểu thế
thì rõ ràng cái kiểu phải có những con
số chính xác ví dụ là đội trễ đọc tội
kiểu chỉ nằm trong phạm vi ở bao nhiêu
đấy, thời gian lưu ở bao nhiêu vân vân
vân vân. Đấy, mức độ sẵn sàng mọi thứ
như nào. Ừ, tôi sẽ nhớ mấy cái này. Tính
nhất quán. Ừ vừa nãy em đề cập về việc
là kiểu bất đồng bộ đấy đúng không? tính
nhất quán tính đồng bộ hay mọi thứ như
nào đấy
công khai có thể tìm kiếm không niêm
biết nhưng ai có link đều xem được riêng
tư con sát thực bảo vệ bằng mật khẩu có
thể chế độ một chế độ khác
đúng rồi
uid bảo đảm xác suất Tạm đường dẫn dài
chưa đáp ứng tốt. À lúc đầu yêu cầu
đường dẫn ngắn à.
Ù tự nhiên quên cái này.
À đúng rồi. Đơn dẫn ngắn là kiểu dạng là
có thể custom lại cái đường dẫn kiểu
dạng slug chẳng hạn. Ừ cũng được.
entropy hay đi duy nhất
con leion này các bạn biết là gì không?
Lion này nhớ không lầm là liên quan đến
việc là để tránh trung lặp
colision.
Fỉ
à tự nhiên giống như kiểu qu mất phím
tắt ấy.
Đúng nhỉ?
Đấy sự trùng lặp đây
đây
vô tình chủng nhau hoặc xung đột nhau
đây nghĩa là nghĩa là kiểu dạng là
để tránh đây tránh xung đột các thứ các
thứ
Đây
đây giống như là anh vừa đề cập ở đây.
Bởi vì sao? Vì ý là kẻo nếu mà
nhớ lại sửa lại là B64 à B64 B62 đấy. Tố
nghe khái niệm B64 ạ. AB62 đấy.
Đây ID phải duy nhất đúng không? Nếu mà
mình tạo ra UID mà lại quá ngắn thì vẫn
có trường hợp ID trùng chẳng hạn. Đấy
đúng không? Đấy hoặc là ID để tự động
tăng rồi dùng B62 thì vẫn còn được nhưng
mà vẫn sẽ có trường hợp nó trùng hay gì
gì đấy. Đấy
B 62
không biết dịch nó có giải thích luôn cá
này không?
chuỗi ngắn kẹo như này
bình thường nghe P 64 ấy nhỉ. Sao có P à
đây đây có rồi này.
Đây 64 ký tự
thương không?
à P64 là dành cho image file token
encoding còn B64 B62 thì dành cho URL
uầy bây giờ mới biết ạ uầy mày không
biết không tôi không nghĩ mày không biết
đâu.
Tương tự a này
cái này chỉ hơn mỗi cái này thôi
thêm hai ký tự gọi tính thêm đúng không?
Ok. Mô hình dữ liệu đang có chi tiết
chưa phục vụ được bài toán không đạt
không được yêu cầu.
Thiếu đề cập về index đúng không?
À content chứ phải context. Ok. Ok. Chưa
giải thích được chưa giải thích. Chọn
máy QL key value store hay object store
dựa trên kích thước nội dung và access
button.
Đúng rồi. Lúc đầu tôi nghĩ là kiểu như
bé bé bé được mình dùng sử đôi khi ở
nhiều nơi là dùng database redit tức là
key về value thôi. Tức là không cần phải
lưu quá nhiều thông tin khác thì mình
phải nói rõ là tại sao mình dùng bảo
thiết cái database
tại sao mình dùng my chẳng hạn. Đấy,
kiểu mình phải hỏi ngược lại cái điều
đấy. Đúng, cái này cũng đề cập thêm hay
này.
Chưa có luồng ghi đọc luồng đấy. Chắc là
lần sau phải ghi rõ mô tả hơn là kiểu
request đi như nào như nào, xử lý tí mọi
thứ như nào xong rồi độ trễ cần bao
nhiêu bao nhiêu vẽ mô hình mơ mết ra.
Mấy ông biết cái mơm mate không? Đây cái
mermade này
vẽ mô hình m mer mm mermade ra
sơ đồ người ta gọi sơ đồ đấy.
Mmm nó là người cá ấy đúng không? Nhà
tên cá nhưng mà nó là cái tên của cái
một dạng kiểu dạng mdown nhưng mà vẽ
chuyên để vẽ sơ đồ.
Trong phỏng vấn hãy hỏi số liệu nếu
không có tự tuyên bố giả định và ước
lượng.
Đây là
cái gì? Chắc là request per second đấy.
Đọc ghi kích thước page và dung lượng để
dẫn tôi quyết định. Ừ. Ok. Kích mới được
nói trong trạ này chưa xử lý hot key.
Đúng rồi. Những cái hot key thì sao đúng
không? Cách học thì sao? Cách stale hoặc
là nhiều request cùng cách meet thì như
thế nào?
Cái vụ cách meet thì giống như kiểu vừa
nãy nói về việc là
à khác về hạ tầng ấy đúng không? khác về
kiểu à khu vực thì sẽ kiểu truy cập đến
nơi khác nhau ấy. Uầy 2007 người xem
rồi. À phải 2007 người lướt qua rồi.
Tôi tin có nhiều người lướt qua hai lần
đấy. Ít nhất là thế.
Ào thật đấy. Dự liệu thống kê không nên
là một lần
kỳ đồng bộ cho mỗi lượt đọc có thể phát
sự kiện. Bộ qua kill.
Ừ đúng rồi. Mình chưa làm vụ thống kê
nhưng mà mình nếu được cặp sâu hơn cũng
có thể.
F link còn trung chung balancer chỉ phân
phối request giữa các tương tự giải
quyết với lỗi mất dữ liệu re trùng thao
tác hoặc cách chữ lỗi kiếu cảnh sát i
rit này quat này về h kích thước chống
spam mã đcap nội dung để tránh xss xác
thực ồ ui một leader phải ngồi cũng ngồi
như này vất vả đấy mà đây không phải
leader nữa đây là một ông nghĩa là một
ông tí architect
chốt ba chế độ truy cập không nhên tư
rõ kiềm chá quyền từng chế độ này đưa ra
giả thuyết giả định có số liệu cụ thể từ
như nào vẽ lại hai luồng tạo và đọc chỉ
rõ cách Stor ui tôi nghĩ là tôi làm xong
được tất cả những cái này. Tôi tự tin đi
phỏng vấn được thật. Khi phỏng vấn tôi
cũng chỉ trả lời mơ hồ mọi thứ theo kiểu
chung chung như ở trên kia.
Tại nói chung là tại sao
lại có series này và mấy ông theo dõi
tôi đủ lâu mấy ông sẽ thấy hồi trước là
tôi dạy về code thôi đúng không ạ?
Nhưng mà anh em sắp nên đến cái tầm mà
không còn là ngồi code nữa, anh em sẽ
quan tâm về việc là sử dụng AI để mà làm
thay việc code đây đúng không ạ? Thì
nhiều người gần đây nhất tôi cũng ngồi
về sinh viên của tôi gọi sinh viên nó
hơi quá vì từng là sinh viên của tôi bây
giờ bạn ấy đi làm rồi mẹ cũng bảo sợ ai
kìa là mình thu chột kỹ năng rồi vân vân
thì tôi cũng nói bạn đấy nhưng kỹ năng
của em chỉ dừng ở việc viết code cái mãi
sẽ là thằng coder thôi thằng thợ thợ
code thợ gõ code đúng không giống như là
anh tôi đi cốt giả thử chia sẻ nghĩa là
Thực sự thì mình sẽ đến cái ngưỡng mà
mình ví dụ là đến một tầm tuổi đó giống
tôi này, tôi sắp đầu ba rồi. Thì hồi
trước hồi trước thì khi mà đến ngưỡng
này một là anh em chuyển sang công việc
khác, hai là phải lên list, phải lên gì
đó và lúc đấy cũng khó mà ngồi đọc, ngồi
cầy được code nữa. Nhưng mà cảm ơn AI
bây giờ mình vẫn sẽ có thể vẫn có thể
làm sinh ra được code và thậm chí nó còn
tốt hơn so với hồi trước. Hồi trước là
làm lead thì anh em phải đi chỉ code cho
người khác
và người ta không đồng ý mình ngồi
review rồi thậm chí là phải vào sửa rất
vất vả. xếp tôi một anh CTO cũng từng
phải làm thế đấy. Bây giờ mình có ai
thích kia mình tự nhảy vào ngồi bảo nó
làm nhưng mà lúc này nó sẽ không mình sẽ
không quan tâm nó về code hay chất lượng
code nữa. Thật sự là đến cái ngưỡng mà
AI đã làm đủ tốt thì mình không quan tâm
về cái chất lượng code nữa. Nếu mà mình
code ngay từ đầu đủ theo một cái design
button nào đó hợp lý thì nó sẽ đề xuất
luôn đề xuất nó code theo đúng cái
format của mình đang làm đấy, theo đúng
cái cấu trúc hay mọi thứ của mình đang
làm nên thành ra nó sẽ không
thể ở code xấu được.
Đấy, tôi từng nói với sinh viên tôi hồi
trước đó là để đánh giá một người kiểu
tư duy và kiểu cái sự tỉ mỉ và rất nhiều
cái gọi tính cách. tính cách của họ chỉ
qua việc họ code nên xem code của họ như
nào họ code có đông đều có thống nhất
hay không kiểu trước sau như một hay
không kiểu trên viết kiểu đặt tên biến
một kiểu dưới đặt tên là kiểu trên thích
thì tab vào hai cái tab vào một cái hay
gì đó ấy đấy kiểu vân vân vân vân đấy
nghĩa là code chỗ này trông kiểu này
code file khác hay trông kiểu khác đấy
mình mà thống nhất được cái điều đấy thì
là hợp lý đúng không giờ có ai rồi tức
là ông chỉ cần cút một lần thôi. À nó
gợi ý ông đúng cái format, đúng cái kiểu
thế mọi chỗ đều giống nhau, đều khớp.
Đấy thì nghe vẻ rất là hợp lý hơn rất
nhiều đúng không? Và đặc biệt là khi mà
một dự án mà nhiều người cùng làm với
nhau là mỗi người sẽ có một cái tính
cách riêng. Con người mà mình vẫn sẽ đặt
cái tính cách của mình vào trong những
dòng code. Đấy có người thì tôi hồi
trước tôi ngựa non hào đá tôi ghi nhận.
cách code của tôi hồi trước trông rất
phải gọi như là dùng từ bẩn thì nó kiểu
tùy the cách bẩn nó gọi là cách kiểu
công ty tôi hay trêu code của giáo sư à
tức là kiểu đọc đọc mãi mới hiểu được v
hồi đấy tôi th code láo tức là code kiểu
muốn cho nó tiện nó nhanh muốn cho nó
kiểu trông nó ngầu kiểu thế rất khó đọc
rất khó sửa rất khó duy trì chỉ có đập
điểm lại thôi
Đấy thì nó là thể hiện tính cách của
mình vào trong đấy. Và và
bây giờ ai nó là đương nhiên nó ông muốn
bảo nó cốt đểu ý nó cũng chửi cho ấy,
ngồi nói lại cho ấy. Nó bảo là thế này
không chuẩn về cái kiểu không chuẩn với
cái gọi prpected à kiểu nó là kiểu
dùng từ chuẩn như nào. Đại khái nó có
một cái quy chuẩt riêng với nó. Đấy. Kểu
thế.
Thì thì anh em sẽ đến cái ngưỡng nào anh
em? Một là chuyển sang vừa có vừa dùng
ai để làm việc vẫn code nhưng mà mình sẽ
làm thêm những cái việc khác mình cần
thêm những cái kỹ năng khác nữa
chứ không chỉ dừng lại việc chỉ biết một
bộ code và code đôi khi anh em còn gọi
nhở làm đi làm lại những cái t mà anh em
đã quá quen thuộc không làm thêm không
bỏ qua việc đọc tài liệu hay mọi thứ
thêm nhá vì tôi nghĩ là những cái người
mà
còn nghe tôi đây chắc là ngoài ra cũng
chưa đến cái ngưỡng mà đi làm cho Google
hay ạ. Cái gì đó khá là cao sang cao
sang không đúng cao xa ấy kiểu rất là
xịn đâu để mà để mà kiểu tôi tin là
những người đang nghe tôi chắc là
gọi như nào không biết đánh đồng như nào
luôn. Thực ra tôi chưa có buổi phỏng vấn
đấy. Tôi tự tin là
kênh của tôi Newbi nhiều hơn SO
nhưng mà tôi vẫn khẳng định có rất nhiều
ông ở đây giỏi hơn tôi. Có tôi chưa
ngưỡng sio đâu. Tôi c đang ngồi học cố
trở thành một ông thôi v đang là middle.
Ngồi đọc đông này còn nhiều cái còn bự
ngỡ lắm.
Nhưng mà ý tôi là những cái ông biết
kênh tôi rồi thì bây giờ có khi không
nghe tôi mấy.
Tự nhiên mình đi nghe cái người kém hơn
mình làm gì đấy. Ui lượt view tăng cứ
tăng đột biến. Cái này bị lag rồi. Lên
người xem rồi à. Ba 31 người lướt qua
nhầm cái ảo rồi
này. Trung bình thời gian xem 12 giây.
Nghĩa là người ta vào nghe tôi hai
12 giây sẽ nói được bao nhiêu từ nhỉ?
Tầm hai câu đấy. Xong thằng thằng trẻ
trâu ở đây xong thoát. Nhưng không sao,
hôm nay tự nhiên được đề xuất quá đỉ vì
tôi cũng chỉ có 10 tầm 11.000 người theo
dõi.
Hồi đấy là chạy quảng cáo trong nhóm J2
từ 11.000 người theo dõi
mà bây giờ mùng 11.300 người chưa ạ? Hồi
trước hình như 11.400 400 như đây cũng
bị giảm đây
mà bây giờ có tậ 3000 người được đề xuất
quá địch này được
quá hạnh phúc rồi
nói chung là buổi hôm nay tại sao tự
nhiên tôi quay lại tâm sự vì buổi hôm
nay mỗi buổi chỉ học
một một bài thôi mà
mấy này hay phết tôi nghĩ ở buổi ngày
hôm sau tôi sẽ a
bởi vì quên mất ấy. Tôi sẽ báo nó làm
lại cho tôi một bài trắc nghiệm để
nhớ lại nó có cái as ở đây mà sẽ tận
dụng cái as nhá. Có gì sẽ hẹn anh em vào
thứ 5 giờ sau.
À gần đây tôi chia sẻ thêm cái nữa cho
anh em nào ở Hà Nội. Đấy gần đây tôi có
tham gia cái
dùng tham gia nó cũng có đúng có một
phần đúng thôi. Tức là kiểu tôi có biết
cái bên Working Space à kiểu cà phê làm
việc ấy. X tôi biết cái kiểu bên a nớt
nớt n
đây đây à không không phải lộ mất rồi
không sao nớt s so society đấy số sự
kiện nớt này hay phết 5 phút để làm để
kể cả tối để làm quen nhau đấy thứ các
thứ đây
tôi đi a
đây không gian này mình ngồi nói chuyện
với nhau đúng kiểu dạ mọ sách nói chuyện
nhau hôm trước tôi thấy là kiểu cũng
phải đến một nửa là dân công nghệ công
tin đấy nĩa là đôi khi là anh em muốn
kiểu giao lưu kết nối đến đây nói chuyện
cũng một cái hay hiện tại tôi thấy nó
đang hơi bị chắc là mới quy mô bé và
đang thử bởi vì mới chỉ lúc nào cũng
trong trạng kín chỗ tôi vừa phải xin đặt
thêm đấy chỉ tầm có 10 người à đâu không
10 người tầm à tập tất cả sẽ tầm 20
người thôi. Ngồi chia sẻ một chủ đề nào
đấy nói xong rồi xong rồi mình ngồi nói
chuyện với nhau cứ thử. Đương nhiên là
chất lượng hơn số lượng bởi vì thật sự
là kiểu mọi người chia sẻ rất là hay
xong rồi nói chuyện sâu được các thứ thứ
ấy. Nhưng ý tôi là kiểu
nếu mà ngoài cái đêm kiểu như thế ra
đúng không? Mình còn muốn nhiều cái kiểu
nói chuyện với nhau thỉnh thoảng ngồi
làm việc với nhau nữa mà đúng không ạ?
Thì chắc là tôi nghĩ là dần dần tôi vẫn
sẽ làm thêm kiểu ừ thực ra là có kênh
Discord ấy mấy ông chắc biết kênh
Discord rồi đúng không ạ? Có kênh
Discord ở trong phần mô tả đấy thì tôi
nghĩa là tôi vẫn sẽ tạo nhiều buổi à
anh em ra đấy ngồi làm việc và kiểu
giao lưu tâm sự chia sẻ luôn. Tôi có
nhóm riêng của tôi về sinh viên tôi rồi
nhưng mà tôi nghĩ thỉnh thoảng anh em
mình thêm người thêm kết nối cũng hay
nếu không có gì cứ vào Discord để
anh em làm quen giới thiệu sau nhá. Tôi
sẽ thỉnh thoảng tạo sự kiện, có thể đi
chơi b game, có thể đi ngồi làm việc cà
phê vân vân vân. Yên tâm mà tôi chưa gửi
thiệp mời cười sớm đâu.
Ok. Còn buổi hôm nay thì chưa thấy anh
em nói thêm gì.
À có bạn chào mình. Xin chào bạn thông
cảm. Kiểu tôi có đọc chat nhưng mà kiểu
mấy ông chat đây bị dịch hết sang tiếng
Anh ấy. Đôi khi tôi cứ phải chỉ vào để
xem nó như nào. Chắc tí tôi sẽ sửa lại
cái quả này chờ sao nó bị chát xang hết
tiếng Anh cay thật đấy.
Chào mấy ông nhá. Không không có có gì
thì nhắn tin qua Discord nhá. Xin chào
mấy ông.
H